hey everyone i'm addie sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
so today's video we are in the kitchen
not my usual kitchen obviously
i've kind of been bouncing between some
airbnbs this summer
so i'm working outside my studio right
now
but of course i'm gonna make this work
for you guys you will be happy to know
that i have finally made my way on to
tick tock
yep despite resisting it for so long
because
it's the wild west out there i also feel
like a little bit of an elder millennial
because i'm struggling to figure it all
out but please give your girl a follow
at abby's kitchen
for lots of diet busting gold
anyways i have been scrolling through
this app and wasting
way too much time doing it but in the
process i've encountered
a treasure trove of diet recipes that
made me feel both a little triggered but
also a little intrigued
i mean i do appreciate when people get
creative in the kitchen
while trying to lose weight or eat
healthier
because let's be real a lot of diet food
out there is really boring and bland
so i thought i would follow these
recipes to the best of my ability
and give you all my unbiased opinion on
them you are welcome
so first my disclaimer on the screen and
in the description
including a trigger warning as i will be
popping up macros
and discussing some eating disorder
behavior so
feel free to skip that if it's not
supportive to your journey
and of course a reminder to subscribe to
the channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on a
video all right first up
we're gonna make a little snack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'm not gonna lie the walden farms
chocolate syrup
a little triggering for me i mean i used
to eat a lot of these
alleged calorie-free products when i was
really deep
in my eating disorder so yeah they taste
like unhappiness to me personally but
i don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with them
if you like them but i also don't think
there's anything inherently wrong with
real chocolate syrup if you like that
but fyi
these foods are actually not calorie
free you can label
something as calorie free as long as it
has less than five calories per serving
so as long as they list the serving in
such a way that they can keep the
calories under
five they can legally state it as being
calorie-free
all right he had some yogurt pb2
and i do love me some pb2 you guys
actually know that this
situation is a snack that i would i
would eat
i like peanut buttery greek yogurt oh my
goodness
i'm making a mess already but then he's
got to go in here with like
a ton of this so gonna have
nightmares tonight oh it's gloopy
and just how
did we get here okay so i think that
that is what it is i'm not gonna do like
a whole like sleeve of rice cakes
because i don't have the appetite to
consume that nor do i want to waste
all my greek yogurt but then he has 30
calories worth of strawberries so
there's that oh my god why am i using a
butter knife to slice
strawberries such a struggle okay so
plop this on
just slap it on and then he's gonna
throw on
the strawberries i'm actually just gonna
make one because let's be real
i'm only gonna have a bite and then he
went in with the cinnamon
okay so that doesn't look so bad right
folks
and now we taste
it's actually pretty good
like i just had two bites that's a good
sign high protein
a little bit of carbs here it's not a
bad snack nutritionally from
the hunger crushing combination
perspective could we use a more
nutritious base
for the yogurt sure but i also don't
think toast would hold up to the yogurt
as well
as like a thick rice cake so i get i get
the choice and obviously also it's got
like 30 calories so
i guess that's what he's going for but
you could also just like use this as a
dip if you wanted
it's not bad it's really not the pb2
makes it though
okay denzo she is i'm just going to eat
this so
all right snack number two
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this video is definitely testing
me
uh it's basically a compilation of
all of the foods that i used to eat
when i was struggling with disordered
eating and fat free cool whip
was like my go-to ice cream
hack anyway sure it is a sweet option
when you're craving like a low calorie
ice cream like texture i guess yeah
there's nothing like really nutritious
going on about it it's really just
just selling put in your mouth that's
what she said that's
my joke damn it dwight but yeah fat free
cool whip is basically like
some combination of hydrogenated oils
and high fructose corn syrup
and flavor i'm not gonna demonize it and
call it poison or toxic
or even like it's not real food if you
like this
but i don't know i'd rather eat real
cream
but less of it if i was trying to lose
weight
it's a good idea i'm not gonna lie i
mean i love me a good graham cracker
ice cream sandwich weren't
oh yeah
that's how she that is how it comes out
it's like foam all right
i mean kind of smart i don't have the
patience to like
do a thorough job but this is good
enough for me
all right cheers
i kind of like it not a lot of flavor
not overwhelmingly sweet
just kind of like cold melts in your
mouth quickly it's okay
i guess i can see the appeal of this
these you know it's got like 20 calories
per two tablespoons so like 10 calories
a tablespoon
and graham crackers are not particularly
high in calories either so i guess it's
not so bad i probably roll this in
sprinkles
just because i know an ice cream bar is
just not fun enough without sprinkles if
you're gonna make an ice cream bar you
gotta throw some sprinkles in there like
chopped nuts or something like that
now it also up the satiety factor make a
little bit more fun
more texture going on because right now
this feels just kind of like foam that
melts in your mouth
you know what i'm saying cool up is
basically just melting film
all right what's next next we're going
savory because i'm an adult
and i can have my sweets first if i want
so let's take a peek see at this
breakfast option
all right let's make this
pam apparently zero calories
but only if you spray it for a fourth of
a second
so yeah not exactly zero calories just
fyi
oh god she said i have to flip it
i am not good at flipping these things
okay i'm not going to flip it it's going
to be
a nightmare if i do so
now turn it down everything bagel
guys know i love this
not bad not the bad okay so she said
now to like let it cool for a second i
don't
know how one handles this
with their hands but we're gonna we're
gonna
we're gonna make it work all right some
ham
we got some chews swiss cheese
a baby spinach a pickle
and the pickle juices are like dripping
onto the hot eggs so i'm not sure how i
feel about that
um okay so
definitely a low fat low carb option
i mean it definitely makes sense for
those on a lower carb diet
i am personally not triggered by calling
like diet foods the names of
other foods when they absolutely are not
those foods like a wrap
i mean i know it's not a wrap i know
it's not a wrap but if you want to call
it a wrap i get what you're saying so
i'm not gonna [ __ ] about that
but i do feel like i would rather eat
this as like an omelette with a fork and
knife
because i'm kind of weirded out by the
idea of picking up
egg whites like these soggy egg whites
with my hands
ugh okay so let's taste despite me
feeling triggered
by the feeling and the like
the squishy sound of egg whites in my
fingers with a
wet pickle in the middle what the [ __ ]
am i eating oh my god
oh no no no no
no oh i
was wrong i was wrong on so many levels
give me back the cool whip
no no didn't like it bad taste in my
mouth yeah
i mean it is probably pretty staging
with all that protein i'll give it that
but if you want to make it more balanced
you could throw it in an actual wrap a
whole grain wrap would be great
or you could add whole eggs or do like
one whole egg or one or two whole eggs
with some egg whites if you want
extra protein in there or you could just
not eat that
at all all right switching gears here we
are going to do
kind of an alfredo noodle
like a low low calorie alfredo
i'm scared
first you're going to want to dump your
noodles into a strainer
[Music]
can't say i'm excited about this one but
here we are
i feel violated i feel violated
just by the smell so this is why
apparently these need to be rinsed and
they need to be
rinsed good
you have been the one for me
if you could see my face right now it's
not enthusiastic
spinach please save us
jesus take the wheel
i'm gonna kill some time as i work up
the courage
to put this in my mouth and tell you
about
a little story
so i first discovered miracle noodles
from hungry girl do you guys remember
hunger girl yeah she still sends out a
bunch of emails
every single day and apparently they all
go to my junk
thankfully but anyways these miracle
noodles
are made of like a high fiber konjac
noodle
or konjac fiber which expands
in your tummy and can sometimes cause
some serious digestive stress
in some folks and probably me and
actually in the worst case scenario it
can even cause
blockages so that's cool but yeah they
mainly just smell really gross to me
i also don't think that this even would
be very satiating at all
because it's just so low in calories
like there's not a whole lot going on
here nutrition wise
so i would way rather use like zucchini
noodles or spaghetti squash noodles
as like a low carb low cal noodle hack
anything that doesn't smell like this
and then i'd also love to see like some
protein added i know she put some
chicken on hers
in the video so yeah that to me is a
must okay
let's do this oh my god
can i spit it out all right i just
swallowed it it's over
i desperately need something better in
my mouth right now that's what she said
that's what she said that's what she
said
good one okay so we're gonna finish with
something sweet because
oh your girl is desperate to
cleanse the palate all right a little
protein explosion
pudding shall we looks good
[Music]
all right well anything can be better
than what i just experienced so
let's do it all right i'm just gonna do
half a portion i think
should be enough for my appetite for
this
sugar-free jell-o
let's blend so this looks a little like
diarrhea like if you were to take
refried beans and then puree them
until they are really really smooth
that's the consistency you get
i was excited about eating this before i
made it
anywho let's try
oh god i think when you stop
consuming a lot of artificial sweeteners
they really overwhelm your palate
nutritionally speaking
we've got some strawberries we've got
some carbs we've got a lot of protein so
that's
definitely probably very satiating but
if this was like a post-workout snack
i'd want to see those carbs bumped up so
you know maybe instead of all that
chocolate syrup on top
we throw on some more fruit
we put some granola in there you know
maybe a drizzle of peanut butter for
some healthy fats that would be a lot
better
that would be super tasty and i would
way rather just
have more of the real cocoa flavor
rather than sugar-free chocolate pudding
yep i'm good so
what have we learned well i would say
that
you know my expectations were low
something surprised me i mean cool whip
you can't have a pie without cool whip
cool whip cool whip yeah you mean cool
whip
yeah cool whip cool whip cool whip not
my favorite
it's not ice cream it tastes a little
bit like melting
foam but like a rice cake
i see the appeal i see why people like
that kind of nostalgic
texture it's it's you know you can't
compare it to whipped cream or ice cream
you just can't
but it is in its own league of
interesting
miracle noodles on the other hand have
got to go oh
i never want to eat another miracle
noodle in my life they
taste like rubber bands to me and they
smell like stinky fish
even after i rinsed the hell out of them
but anywho if you're on tick tock
definitely give me a follow at abby's
kitchen
you won't see me using a lot of diet
products and making recipes that are
like
low calorie or calorie free but you will
see me busting a lot of nutrition myths
and taking down diet culture
so for more abby's kitchen goodness
check me out on tik tok
and if you want to see me review more
tik tok recipes and more
tik tok content leave me a comment below
until then i hope you guys enjoyed this
video please be sure to give it the
thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to abby's
kitchen i'll see you next time
bye
you